[Musique]
bonsoir mes enfants ou ce patron d'accor
mon gros nounours tu leur montre le
livre et moi je leur en raconte
l'histoire moins jeunes aux propos au
bon soir qu'est ce que t'as pas de tête
respecte vous allez voir c'est un livre
c'est la suite d'une histoire que vous
aimez pourquoi exactement les enfants
là on sache roi nous possédons pas comme
ça aliens
à vous
octros avant patron donc chu et son
petit arles et en reviennent du marché
ils ont acheté un gros sac de pépins de
pomme que le petit chinois a l'intention
de planter dans leur jardin pour faire
pousser de jolis pommier rose
il est courageux ces petits chinois
silence nicolas coutelot plus tôt il
marche sur la grande route et passe sur
un ravissant pont chinois en bambou
quand tout à coup et on où se met à
crier le petit âne qui s'arrête
ça y est c'est gros vilain j'en suis sûr
on y inclut chu regarde en bas du pont
et il voit au bord de la rivière
le gros vilain un filet de pêcheur à la
main qui court après un poisson ils
courent pas les poissons dénonce images
sont pas un poisson de mille couleurs
un poisson qui a des ailes comme celle
d'une libellule un poisson qui vole un
poisson volant donc su se met en colère
il lève son bâton en l'air et papa pas
sur la tête à gros vilain non gros
vilain dès qu'il a vu le bâton est parti
se cacher sans insister le petit chinois
s'approche du poisson volant qui est
devenu bleu de peur et lui dit aux
petits poissons les élus tu sais
il y a dans mon jardin une rivière qui
coule encore plus claire que celle ci
vient avec nous le poisson volant
accompagne 10 ans ayant reçu jusqu'à la
rivière ce qui vole bien ce poisson
volant il va être content championnat
mythe plus tu voles pas toi aussi
joe folles les enfants sur mon nuage jo
ford et par les beaux soirs d'été
liang chu de petits chinois et son ami
ans regardent leur nouvel ami le poisson
volant danser dans les rayons de la lune
comme une lanterne magique le rebord
histoire merci des marchands de salon
les petits os tout haut
[Musique]
bonne nuit le petit long là j'ai eu lieu
à 2
pour lui le nom elle est même venu
nicolas ce premier pas bonne elle bonne
nuit petit pape rhône elle bonne nuit
petit nicolas bonne nuit tous les
enfants allaient sagement vous coucher
et faites de beaux rêves fait deux
bourses aux voiles au patro alors en
route vers le nord bonne nuit à demain
un pub pour le doute
[Musique]